après montpellier un bref passage par
magny les hameaux la fédération
française d'échecs a finalement pris ses
quartiers à elancourt dans la
commanderie des templiers samedi un
déménagement prévu depuis 2005
pour henri carvallo président de la
fédération l'implantation sur un site
templiers et symboliquement intéressant
on est très heureux d'être dans une
commanderie templière vous avec les
échecs sont un sport mais mais sont
aussi très culturelle et sont venus
d'orient et je suis que les templiers
ont contribué au passage du jeu d'échecs
du monde oriental au monde de l'occident
médiéval
l'objectif de ce déplacement est de se
rapprocher de paris donc des
institutions et d'éventuels partenaires
voire sponsors évidemment
saint-quentin-en-yvelines profitera de
la présence de la fédération des
collaborations sont déjà envisagés avec
la base de loisirs et pourquoi pas
d'autres fédérations sportives du
territoire comme le golf et le cyclisme
autre terrain de prédilection pour la
fédération française d'échecs les écoles
aujourd'hui c'est plus spécifiquement
sur elancourt qui a une un projet
pédagogique qui implique l'ensemble des
écoles de la ville d'elancourt dont il
ya des cours d'échecs qui sont donnés
manches chacune chacun des seize groupes
scolaires de la ville est en cours ce
serait une bonne idée que d'essayer de
redimensionner sa halle à l'échelle du
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
à l'échelle nationale la fédération
compte soixante mille licenciés
événement de taille dans le milieu le
championnat de france des équipes le top
12 est prévue pour l'an prochain dans
les locaux de la chapelle de la
villedieu